Crossing the Pacific
to raise awareness for ocean health
may have more in common with a long-term space mission than you'd think.
BEN: Even if it's high seas and lots of
waves in the water,
I'm just bobbing up and down like a little cork,
and I don't feel the motion of the ocean, really.
I can imagine that it's close to what
they would feel in space.
Long-distance swimmer Ben Lecomte is spending
eight hours a day in the water,
meaning his body will likely experience similar effects
to an astronaut in spaceflight–
particularly, the rapid atrophy of his bones.
ADRIAN: If you put somebody in the water and they're just buoyant, that's just like being in space.
The body, in both cases, has almost zero
gravity effects on the musculoskeletal system.
And the normal response of the skeleton is, when you put it in disuse, it begins to remodel and get rid of it.
The astronauts have shown consistent losses
of 1-1.5% a month.
Clinically, to a doctor looking at somebody who's gonna lose that kind of mass... they'd be concerned.
Scientists at NASA have been trying to combat this deterioration for decades,
But this requires detailed research on how the skeleton responds to low gravity –
a tall order for your typical earth-bound science lab.
One surprising way to simulate zero-g
is using swimming pools.
Now, scientists have an entire ocean to work with, as Ben's swim is providing researchers
an unparalleled opportunity to study
human physiology at its limits.
PAUL: It's also a risk that Ben's taking,
being in the ocean for that long every day, something that no one has ever done before.
We don't know, what are the consequences
on the human body?
BEN: In the water, it's totally different. It's a feeling
of not feeling your body at all...
I don't feel the gravity.
ADRIAN: It's very rare than anybody spends
months in the water.
Because of the lack of forces, you'd lose bone just like they do in spaceflight.
I thought, 'well, this would be a good opportunity to do some bone measurements
where somebody's been in the water for that long.'
Pre- and post-swim, Adrian and his lab made plans to collect information on Ben's total lean mass
and body fat percentage, and conduct
Dual X-ray Absorptiometry,
or DXA scans, on his spine, hip, and heel bone.
Ben's data may confirm findings that astronauts suffer the most damage to weight-bearing structures,
like the calcaneus, or heel bone, and their entire skeleton's spongy internal architecture
also known as trabecular bone.
ADRIAN: We did find, in one of our studies,
that the trabecular bone is lost
at about twice the rate as the overall bone.
Those trabeculae are like struts on a bridge.
Once you lose that connectivity,
it's very difficult to recover that.
But recovering this loss, and preventing it in the first place, is one of NASA's most urgent concerns...
especially if long-term spaceflight is ever
to become a reality.
Current strategies have focused on exercise and pharmaceuticals.
ADRIAN: They have recently put a device up there called Advanced Resistive Exercise Device,
and this allows the astronaut to put
very high loads on their skeleton,
as you would on  Earth.
If you add a bisphosphonate to that,
an anti-resorptive drug,
you pretty much can protect the bone mass. The problem is each of those things have their downside.
Too much strenuous resistive exercise, and an astronaut runs a high risk of getting injured;
Too heavy a drug regimen and they're subject to unwanted side-effects.
ADRIAN: Ben, he's doing aerobic activity all day.
The question is, would that be enough to protect the skeleton? If it doesn't, that means that no amount
of aerobic activity in space is ever going to work.
If it does, it may lead the researchers
to come up with a better protocol
to protect the skeleton.
If we ever need to live in a harsh environment like space, protecting our bodies will be crucial.
But if we can better protect our ocean's health
here on Earth,
living in space may not have to be our only option.
Be sure to visit Seeker.com/TheSwim
to read daily updates from Ben Lecomte,
track his progress in real-time, and watch more videos about the science happening onboard Seeker.
Click here for this next episode,
and don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching!